it looks like the never-ending
impeachment hearings just ended about 60
seconds ago like an HR meeting convened
in hell the whole Ukraine impeachment
saga is boring hard to understand and
apparently goes on for eternity it never
ends
Washington endured and the rest of
America ignored yet another round of it
today the hearings consumed virtually
every hour of Wednesday's available
daylight in elevated to international
celebrity this country's current
ambassador to European Union a man
called Gordon Sandlin in contrast to
other recent witnesses someone wasn't
obviously hostile to the administration
in fact he was appointed directly by
President Trump he was also a major
Trump donor so given those two facts on
one's opening statement this morning
initially looked like a complete
disaster for the administration I know
that members of this committee
frequently framed these complicated
issues in the form of a simple question
was there a quid pro quo as I testified
previously with regard to the requested
White House call and the White House
meeting the answer is yes so that's how
the morning began the answer is yes said
Gordon Sullivan there was a print quid
pro quo and not only that he explained
pretty much everybody knew about it
everyone was in the loop it was no
secret
everyone was informed via email on July
19th days before the presidential call
holy smokes for a moment there it looked
like case closed
the final ignominy ascends of the Trump
presidency the one that are perpetually
excitable friends in the news media have
been confidently predicting day after
rage-filled day for more than three
years now the last meltdown the great
orange Hindenburg finally bursts into
flame than TV studios across midtown
Manhattan cable news contributor
struggled to hold back tears of joy and
then Adam Schiff took the microphone
ship as the ringmaster of this
particular circus was determined to
bring it to its final theatrical close
tell us at
Schiff said about president Trump's deal
with Ukraine to investigate Joe Biden in
return for foreign aid was the moment
Democrats have been waiting for but when
it finally arrived
Gordon Sandlin wouldn't read from the
script though President Trump claimed
you there was no quid pro quo he also
made it clear to you in that call that
President Solinsky had to quote clear
things up and do it in public
you'd have a reason to dispute that's
right I don't have any reason to dispute
the clear things up and do it in public
what I'm trying to be very clear about
was President Trump never told me
directly that the aid was tied to that
state but in that same conversation you
had with him about the aid about the
quid pro quo he told you that President
Solinsky had to quote clear things up
and do it in public I did not have a
conversation with him about the aid I
had a conversation with him as
referenced in my text about quid pro quo
well the quid pro quo you were
discussing was over the aid correct no
president Trump when I asked him the
open-ended question as I testified
previously what do you want from Ukraine
his answer was I want nothing I want no
quid pro quo tell zolensky to do the
right thing that's all I got from
President Trump so they pushed him and
they pushed him and they pushed him
again but Gordon Soglin would not in the
end mouth
Adams shifts talking points well why not
maybe because he didn't have any
evidence that they were true as someone
conceded in an exchange with congressman
michael turner his assessment of any
deals Trump may have struck with Ukraine
was based mostly on assumptions no one
on this planet told you that President
Trump was tying aid to investigations
yes or no yes so you really have no
testimony today that ties President
Trump to a scheme to withhold aid from
Ukraine in exchange for these
investigations other than my own
presumption which is nothing this is
tiresome and of course we apologize for
us we have a nice pass but since it's
happening we we feel duty-bound to
explain it so a presumption
now some presumptions are correct others
are laughably wrong but one thing
presumption definitely isn't is evidence
you can't overturn an election based on
a presumption you can't stage an
impeachment on presumptions you need
facts to do that and as the day went on
Sandlin introduced a new fact the
president garden someone told us had
told him explicitly that he in fact
didn't want a quid pro quo with Ukraine
you said to the President of the United
States what do you want from Ukraine the
president I want nothing I want no quid
pro quo I won Solinsky to do the right
thing I want him to do what he ran on
why didn't you put that statement in
your opening statement I think you said
you couldn't fit it in is that right say
we might be here for 46 minutes and it
wasn't five sounds purposeful trust me
wasn't purposeful no couldn't fit it in
a 23-page opener it's a fair question
actually so why wasn't that fact and
it's not a small point by the way it's
the point on which the entire
impeachment hangs why wasn't that point
included in someone's opening statement
well we don't know really but here's one
possible explanation the statement was
likely drafted by sonless legal team and
all four of his attorneys it turns out
because we checked our Democratic donors
the man seated next to Gordon Sandlin
today during the hearing that would be a
man called Robert Luskin he has given
over a hundred and thirty thousand
dollars to the Democrats over the years
less can also represent an FBI informant
Stephane halper during the Russia hoax
not too long ago so is it possible that
someone like Luskin was thinking about
more than his clients personal interests
in this case could impeaching public
enemy number one have crossed his mind
we don't know but it doesn't seem
implausible we should also point out
something the press conveniently
overlooked in its analysis today for the
most part gordon sangla and his family
have been under intense political
pressure in some cases scary political
pressure from the left for weeks
protesters have swarmed Gordon Sandlin
and his family in public Democratic
politicians have endorsed boycotts
pushed
boycotts of his businesses his
livelihood in other words the left has
been working the RAF's
and that shouldn't surprise you because
for the left this is total war and yet
in this one case it didn't quite work
but it closed a business today we were
back right where we were when the
Ukraine's Circus started in fact we're
back where we were on November 9th 2016
yes a lot of people in Washington
despised Donald Trump but still to this
moment nobody can prove a crime
don't tell the press though they're
celebrating as if someone did now we
know that every fantasy about how
corrupted this administration was is
actually true our live coverage of the
blowtorch testimony this morning from
Gordon Sunland turns out to be the guy
who has offered the most stunning
testimony in addition to that and the
bombshells we've heard about this was an
AED from mr. Sandlin as you said taking
a blowtorch to every defense donald
trump has offered we don't say this very
often anymore because it's rarely true
but I think today changed everything so
you heard it bombs shells IEDs blow
torches who raised the metaphors for
these hair hats
it sounds like today's hearing was
taking place in Isis territory in the
caliphate but the really telling line
comes from the scene and legal analyst
and recording now every fantasy about
how corrupt this administration was is
actually true so pause for a minute
think about what he's telling you all of
the fantasies the press has held without
evidence are true based on testimony
from another person who doesn't have
evidence so you remember the Russia
collusion story number stormy Daniels
remember every totally baseless in some
cases insane allegation that people like
Cena's legal analyst invented and
promoted and used to try to effect
elections and in so doing destroyed
lives well they're telling us that all
of them were true because of our
presumptions that's the most revealing
thing in all of this from the beginning
Washington has had presumptions about
what the new president was like about
what policies voters were allowed to
choose voters weren't allowed to end
Foreign Wars by casting a ballot when
put America first or to secure America's
borders that's not on the table
those aren't menu options this isn't a
real democracy according to the people
who administered the democracy and by
the way that ought to make you nervous
you come to Washington the city that's
in charge of our democracy and no one
believes in it you're like if you shut
up in Detroit and everyone's driving a
Japanese car would it make you nervous
it it would they don't believe in it and
so what they're really saying to voters
is you can't actually make changes to
American policies the ones that we
support all you're allowed to do is
rubber stamp the current status quo the
one that enriches private equity
managers and defense contractors and
parasites in the vast federal
bureaucracies our donors and friends
other than that shut up and obey so
that's their program and maybe they'll
succeed in the end maybe they'll remove
the president okay what then well
Washington will celebrate of course but
will they have learned anything from the
exercise well the 2016 election have
changed their minds or their priorities
at all in any way or they continue to
console themselves that the whole thing
was just some weird aberration run by
Russian racists in the heartland
something that they can safely ignore
and return to a kind of arrangement
looks very much like 1998 or 1978 for
that matter well you know the answer to
that if the people in charge were
capable of learning anything our country
wouldn't look like it does today